found the line [ __ ]
[Music]
hi i'm ian fidenz and i'm here to answer
the internet would you rather lose a leg
or never be able to have sex again
i'll tell you
i walked around with a cane and it
[ __ ] rolled dude
take the leg all right dude people were
like where's this i'm like over you're
under you know dude you take the cane
hit someone in the chest you know you're
speaking to me pal
yeah yeah you say something you put a
point on it with a stamp of the cane
i want to get a wooden cane with a skull
and a knife in it you know if you could
be the patron saint of something what
would it be eating ass
i feel like you were you were early on
the eating ass train i was if i bought
stock in eating ass i'd be a millionaire
right now
that and trans women um
[Laughter]
the first time that you watch some porn
like that and you're like this is kind
of like you know better
everything you've ever wanted
yeah the best of like a miley cyrus song
the best of both worlds
is actually i would be the patron saint
of um
kindness love and compassion
[Music]
[Applause]
is sex with conjoined twins a threesome
yes dude it's two
freaks in you
like
i mean you're already getting freaky
like one is that what if it's one brain
then you're committing a crime because
you're having sex with a clearly
mentally handicapped person
it means someone's got half a brain that
you're banging like banging a poodle
what if it's one
set of genitalia that's one i meant and
two heads yeah oh whoa i didn't think of
that
okay
it's if you're getting dome from two of
the heads that's a threesome and if
you're just banging the puss
with two bodies attached to it then that
is [ __ ] a chick while her sister
watches it
yeah
and you'll probably get a show on dlc
what if you fell in love with one half
of a
conjoined twin
like what would you do like and the
other i mean this is this isn't coney
island i'm not on a freak show there's
no way that's happening
are you swiping right on conjoined twins
on twitter
if i see one eyelash longer than the
other it's left
you're on stage right you look out in
the crowd you see the most beautiful
girl you've ever seen in your life you
tell the manager leave me leave her my
[ __ ] little did you know that like that
girl sitting at the table with her was
connected to her yeah how do you know
this is the most beautiful girl and the
manager gives her my number yeah then
she calls it i let's meet up and then
she shows up and she's a good job i
treat it like a travis scott concert i
pushed my way to the front and i yanked
the number away from her all right
that's what's happening
i'm stamped through to make sure those
freak shows never contact me
all right
evidence hey all you freaks stay out of
my dms
i'm in love with a gal
and we have cats who's the freak now
uh if you could be homeless in any city
where would you choose well i guess if i
could be homeless in any city
it would be uh
paradise city by guns and roses thank
you
dude you definitely want to do a beach
town yeah yeah that would be sick that's
why santa monica is such a nightmare
dude everyone's like i can just be
homeless in a tent do drugs and surf
hell yeah dude you just do heroin and
that keeps you warm at night it's the
best scenario is eating in bed gross
whoa uh
all depends what you're eating and all
depends if you have like a tray or
something
for crumbs to fall on if you're eating
cookies in bed you're a piece of [ __ ]
all right
a bowl of cereal peanut butter and jelly
sandwich and some cheese puffs and a
bunch of candy
are you stuart little what the [ __ ] is
the matter with you dude i picture you
doing that in a full pajama bodysuit
with a night cap and a candle
lit like going to [ __ ] bed with all
your little nighttime snacks
the crumbs in your bed must be out of
here oh it's
do you vacuum how do you get how do you
get them out i don't see that you just
thought about it until you just asked he
just sleeps on the crumbs bro i mean
can i get your dyson how often do you
wash your sheets no not often enough for
that i have once a month max when did i
when i fall asleep on that reese's bar
i was just saying it was not a joke that
was a genuine [ __ ]
that was a marker of time for you
that's incredible dude one of the
funniest things you ever said and you
did not say that with a hint of a joke
no hey back me up on this man when was
uh the last time i fell asleep my human
filth remember when i came in here with
a rich cracker up my ass when was that
oh [ __ ] man i forget he had come
standing on his pants on the outside of
his pants at work
what it was like sweatpants that had
like jerked off in and i guess it wasn't
a full load it was like it was enough
dude the key word there is load i don't
care if it's a quarter full or half a
tank you still got comb on your clothes
bro
what the [ __ ] i will not judge though
because i one time i showed up to a
wedding with a [ __ ] stain on the back of
my suit
on the back yeah catching backwards well
yeah yeah cause i pulled out was like
and uh it looks like when i call my go
get zooks so i gave her the old gadzooks
and i guess it like landed on my like
suit on the ground oh [ __ ] yeah it
wasn't like i did a trick shot
kardashian yeah yeah yeah yeah hey babe
you'll see something
i'm my own grandpa and i'm coming on my
own back would you punch your grandma in
the face to [ __ ] the girl of your dreams
guess what already [ __ ] the girl in my
dreams and old grammy's dead
[Laughter]
dig her up
if you could die and come back as any
inanimate object what would it be
uh probably cindy crawford's bicycle
seat
that's a throwback she was my number one
crush
oh or rihanna's [ __ ] thong oh my god
whoa or maybe one of the crackers she
leaves in bed what do you think of that
fighter
oh dude
some of those caribbean farts
[Laughter]
if you could only watch one actor's
movies for the rest of your life who
would it be
bill [ __ ] murray the king
would you rather have your dick as your
nose or your nose as your dick
whoa
i would rather have
my nose as a dick because i think i'd
really enjoy the smells of what my
little fella gets into
you know
what's going on down there big guy huh
polar opposite like i would do the
opposite for that reason yeah you would
have a dick for her nose
flopping around wherever you go here
comes old dick nose i can't really [ __ ]
with a nose
yeah you you've never shoved your nose
in an [ __ ]
or a [ __ ] but it's never yeah yeah yeah
i wear like a sleep apnea mask would you
rather have no music for the rest of
your life or have all music be sung by
your significant other what
uh let me tell you something life is not
worth living if i can't listen to ska
so i will choose significant other
singing what do you think is the oldest
someone's been when they've had sex i
bet there's some 90 year olds that [ __ ]
it's probably hard to [ __ ] when you got
to remove your catheter beforehand
found the line [ __ ] who was the one
person in the world you would least want
to bang your significant other oh my god
probably like my mom that would be weird
right any nba player any
college athlete would you rather be
falsely accused of murder or never be
able to stop coming holy [ __ ] it all
depends on who's my lawyer
call johnny cochran and i'm in you know
he puts a [ __ ] and cocker in for that
one
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon